did you get more nervous for opening day
or for Game one of the playoffs playoffs
why well because is that's what you
dream for you know your dream to win and
you know if you win during the playoffs
obviously you're gonna keep advancing so
that first game the playoffs is more
about Game one of the playoffs are game
seven over playoffs Oh game stuff
there's no doubt you know when you're
like either going home or advancing it's
just everybody's a little bit nervous
that day alright obviously baseball's
your favorite sport but would you say
that you prefer a football or football
NFL football I will say NFL football now
really now so at one point it was the
all because there's certain time that
you know the World Cup and stuff comes
around as it's exciting so I like both
but I think right now I'm enjoying a
little bit more NFL okay who's your
favorite team Cowboys Cowboys really ok
how about this one this is a good one oh
the Yankee Stadium or new Yankee Stadium
I love all Yankee Stadium I uh you know
the things that we had in new Yankee
Stadium and the things that but all
Yankee Stadium had a different feel you
know it was very very unique I just had
a good it just felt so it fell home you
know like and then but the new stadium
has a lot of things that we needed to
prepare for a ball game I think it was
much much needed it's designed for a
modern to a modern sport how about the
what's the food or dish that you most
miss in New York City when you're away
from the city when you're in Florida and
you come back what do you miss the most
and what do you want to have right away
you know what would go to different
restaurants my my go to restaurant a
style I like going to town so what's
your favorite dish sir last night I had
the Kobe certainly alright how about
this one what's your best George
Steinbrenner story mr. Steinbrenner
would always come around and ask me
about little Jorge he will always wanted
to know if he was doing well if he made
it if I needed anything from him so he
was very kind to us which current
athlete do you most admire right LeBron
James LeBron James
I think everything is doing you know
winning is is so important to him and
you can tell that he really really cares
about his teammates and make him you
know it's kind of like seeing a little
bit of Derek Jeter in him